so there's two movies everybody was
warning me about when I was beginning
doing these direct-to-dvd sequels
one was the third Beauty and the Beast
and you can rightfully see why and the
second was Kronk's New Groove this is
one of the Disney sequels everybody
points to when they want to see how bad
they can get yeah yeah it's not good
it's just a bunch of unfunny stories
with unfunny jokes I guess it's a little
difficult to be offended when it's
obviously not trying that hard I mean
don't get me wrong there's obviously
money thrown into the animation and it
moves a lot but the slapstick is pretty
dull the jokes all fall flat and I just
felt like I watched a whole bunch of
nothing the film centers around the
henchman cross played by Patrick
Warburton he's nervous because his
disapproving father is coming in to
visit and as we go into three different
stories about what were they again the
evil villain wasn't back as a henchman
of romance step ones with a counselor
and him trying to convince his father
but he has everything he's been looking
for all of them are pretty forgettable I
guess on the one hand I can see why
people would be so upset because a lot
of people really like the first movie I
just kind of I was okay but to its
credit it had a lot more labs than this
movie does in fact half the movie it's
just trying to catch in on those labs
again remember the devil and angel in
the first one they do that like 20 times
in this how even a little kid can angel
and devil and half the jokes don't make
any sense
the devil makes fun be angel because you
wears a dress they all wear dresses it's
a time period some of these jokes have
great build-up but then no payoff when
crock is about to be reunited with the
villain there's all these jokes about
beware as a cat that cats going to get
you and all these other feline jokes
obviously they're building up that the
villain is still going to be a cat which
is a funny idea this little cat popping
him around and trying to do all these
evil things that's funny but no all you
have is a tail how is that humorous
that's not fun how much funnier would it
be as this whole story happened while
she was a cat a teeny tiny cat to be a
lot more humorous on top of it there's a
lot of great talent that they got for
this movie patrick warburton
Eartha Kitt's Tracey Ullman John Mahoney
John Goodman
these are all funny voices that belong
to funny actors
yet none of them are allowed to be funny
they just gotta show up say the lines
and say them well they're just not funny
lines to say it's even a totally
pointless cameo from David Spade as the
Emperor he literally just comes in to
say he's in the movie nothing else and
he'll come in say a few lines and then
just disappear
he'll the way I'm describing that sounds
funnier than how they actually do it
it's just kind of confusing it awkwardly
done the slapstick is also kind of
boring they just kind of bounce around
and move in exaggerated ways but it
doesn't feel like there's any focus or
control
there's just big movements going on
because that's what kids like a watch
right right
so okay obviously this is not a good
movie is it god awful um I don't know I
guess it kind of depends maybe because
I've seen so many bad comedies that
really hurt after a joke is told I don't
see this one as offensive it's kind like
a joke you see on Family Guy or an Adam
Sandler movie where when it's told and
it's bad it's really bad like you're put
in a bad mood here to its credit the
movie seems so determined to get itself
over with as quickly as possible that
the jokes just kind of fly by they never
linger there's no awkward pauses it's
just kind of joke joke joke joke joke
and then the movies done it clearly
doesn't have that much to say or what it
does have to say it doesn't try that
hard at so for me just one of those
movies that goes in one ear and out the
other
yeah I wish it could have been better
because the villains I thought were the
best part of the first movie but what it
is it's just bad it's not the words not
insulting just thanks if you have little
kids that just want to see some cartoons
bouncing I guess it's fine
but you're a fan of the Emperor's New
Groove or even not a fan yeah I
recommend just watching a funny movie to
dance away from this as fast as you can
you
[Music]